Welcome back to the next episode of
what's up, Prof? Good day, Walter.
Good day, young Martin. How are you
doing? I'm doing just fine. I bashed my
finger and it's black and blue.
But it's just reminder of our
humanity. So, yes. So, you took it as it
came. As it came, yeah.
So, you've got
some new windows.
Yes.
No scratches. No. I won't be able to
read because
I said I used to the scratches.
Yeah.
Now, it looks good.
Let's open with a word of prayer.
Our heavenly Father, thank you very much
for
bringing us together again.
Lord, we
again ask that you bless us and we also
want
the Holy Spirit to enlighten our minds
and help us discern. In Jesus' name,
amen. Amen.
So many things happening in the world,
we can't keep up.
No, you
That's true. It's just like a snowball.
It's just roaring. Yeah, we're busy with
trying to prepare something like this
and then all of the sudden Something
else happens.
It comes from everywhere. So, yeah.
Yeah.
It's not what we
how we plan every time. No. The Lord
puts these things together.
It's not possible to plan these things.
We have to just go with the flow
and ask the Lord to help us through all
of these. So, we've titled this one
prophetic movements.
Because
we said last time that we were going to
go into the Bible and show this and
that, but
we have to deal with with the current
events. I mean, we have to put them into
the
into the prophetic picture. So,
yes, we'll we'll talk about some of
these things.
Yeah, what's happening?
I think the
portion of the Bible that says the Or is
it the Bible that says or the spirit of
prophecy that says the final movements
will be rapid ones? That's the spirit of
prophecy.
somewhat the case. But the Bible says
that the reaper
will overtake the sower. Mhm. So, that
also tells you that it will be very
rapid here towards the end.
Yeah. And you're still trying to sow and
here the reapers are coming already. I
mean, it really is like that at the
moment. Yes.
So, we have put together
a lot of videos.
And uh
I don't know whether everybody out there
understands how many videos you have to
view.
Yeah, how many hours of viewing? You
have to try and put in and we only have
1 week every time.
Mhm.
And there are so many things that are
absolutely irrelevant.
Yes.
That you cannot use.
to sift through it. And what fits into
the picture and what does not fit into
the picture.
And I just want to make it quite clear
that humanly it's not possible at all.
I acknowledge. It's not possible. It's
not possible.
So, if God doesn't help us,
then it would never happen. No.
So, we've put it together quite a number
of videos and we would like to just
discuss them in terms of the prophetic
picture.
And not only the prophetic picture, the
doctrinal picture.
Yes.
And where we are in relationship to this
beautiful book over here.
So,
let us start with some of the things
that are happening in the world. Just a
few news items and then we'll go into
what is currently uh taking place on the
world stage, what is grabbing the
attention of humanity, and how they are
running with it and perhaps running
towards a precipice.
And it looks like a good
um
goal that that might be running towards.
Absolutely, but it's a precipice.
Okay. So, what's new? I mean, some of
it's not new anymore, but nevertheless
it's still worth talking about.
The New York Times told us this month
that a clock has been uh
put in place that used to be just a
normal clock, which was also a little
bit of a strange clock, apparently.
But this one tells us how much time
there is remaining and I and I just
thought it would be interesting because
we had a lecture
uh I'm almost scared to go there. I
think it's number was number eight, to
which was added number nine,
where we mentioned a date. Mhm.
Of course, we didn't mention that date
in terms of the end, but just a
deduction from the spirit of prophecy.
And the year that we mentioned was 2027.
Mhm.
And it caused quite uh
quite a little bit of excitement in the
world.
Now, this clock is what some people call
a doomsday clock
and it tells you the number of years and
the number of days and the number of
hours and the number of minutes that are
left before we run out of time in terms
of climate change.
Mhm.
I'm not saying it's the end of the
world, but uh in terms of climate
change, that's the deadline. Now, these
guys are brilliant.
They've got it down to the minute. Even
the second.
I I think some people should write
articles against this. I mean, this is
time setting like like you cannot
believe, right?
Anyway,
so what happens?
For more than 20 years, Metronome, which
includes a 62-ft
wide 15-digit electronic clock
that faces Union Square in Manhattan has
been one of the city's most prominent
and baffling public art projects.
So, it displayed the time and some
people in the past thought, you know,
there were other issues that were hidden
in that, but nevertheless, let's read
the highlighted part.
On Saturday, Metronome adopted a new
ecologically sensitive mission. Now,
instead of measuring 24-hour cycles,
it is measuring what two artists, Gan
Golan and Andrew Boyd, present as a
critical window for action
to prevent the effects of global warming
from becoming irreversible.
Well, I'm glad we've got it down to the
minute.
On Saturday, 3:20 p.m. messages
including the Earth has a deadline began
to appear on the display.
Then the numbers
7 103 15 40 07 showed up representing
years, days, hours, minutes, and
seconds. Oh, I stand corrected, down to
the second.
We definitely need an article against
this form of time setting, don't you
think? Yes.
"This is arguably the most important
number in the world," Mr. Boyd said.
"And a monument is often how a society
shows what's important, what it
elevates, what is at the center stage."
So, they described this project and they
created a webpage called
climateclock.world.
Well,
so 2027
in the 103rd
day from when it was erected, the 15th
hour, and the 12th minute, and then the
seconds.
Then they say that's the deadline for
irreversible
climate change. I'm I'm always amazed
how accurate people can be.
Now, what do they actually have to say
about this issue? Let's have a look at a
little discussion
that they had with the artists.
And what a climate clock shows is a
string of numbers, and those numbers are
really important, arguably the most
important numbers in the world right now
right now. And what they are saying
right at this moment is that we have 7
years and 101 days
to take action on climate change to
prevent the effects of climate
catastrophe from becoming irreversible.
You know, the media loves to be
sensationalist and say, "This is a
doomsday clock." Like, you know, it's
counting down and in 7 years the world
is going to explode. That's not what the
clock shows, right? It is showing our
time window for action. This is the best
period of time that we have to really
make a difference.
And the world will go to hell later.
This number has been around for a while.
This is we didn't make up this number.
This is number has been scientifically
accepted for years.
The problem is that people are not
paying attention to it. So, we realized
that we had to turn it into a monument,
literally, in public space to give it
the kind of monumental importance it
deserves. We're encouraging other cities
to start to install their own monumental
clocks, but like what can you know, what
can high school students do? What can we
do, you know, to spread the word more?
So, what we've done is we've actually
built a smaller version of the clock
that you can make yourself. You can
order the parts and you can have one as
a high school classroom could do it.
Um and it's something that, you know,
you can learn about climate, you can
build your own clock, but then you have
this messaging tool to tell other people
what's up and and again, it's to get all
of us on the same timeline. It's like to
This is mission impossible or nearly
impossible, but we can do it, but we
need to synchronize our watches, right?
That's the key thing. All get on the
same page. Please.
And also, isn't this uh this is kicking
off climate week, is it not? There's
there's like a series of uh events and
and marches and things that are kind of
culminating in this next uh week to 10
days, is that right?
It's a it's a We we launched the clock
at the very opening of climate week and
um it's a it's a whole week of of many
events and seminars and educational
sessions. Unfortunately, this year
because of COVID, it's largely virtual,
so no marches. I think on Friday, you
know, in as part of the Fridays for
Future movement that Greta Thunberg
started where millions of young people
are recognizing that as older people are
failing them and they're taking matters
into their own hands. They're going to
be I think in There's 2,500 different
youth led events that are happening on
Friday.
Who you calling old? And all those young
people who are out on the streets to be
able to point to it. And every time they
get pushed back from politicians or oil
executives is saying, "Oh, it's too
fast. We can't do it. You know, it's too
expensive." They can keep pointing to
that clock and say, "You can't argue
with that. You can't tell me that my
future is less than whatever it is that
you're talking about." So, we're
providing a tool for all of the good
people who are doing the hard work to
strengthen what they're doing. Right. We
like to think of it as we're not just
creating a monument, we're helping to
create a movement.
Now, that was a little bit more
detailed. Mhm. Of where it comes from
and why. So, who's dictating the clock?
The scientists.
Do you think it's possible that the
religious world can latch onto the
scientific opinion and say that
something of a religious nature must be
implemented because science demands it?
Mhm. Definitely. So, has science become
a god? Oh, definitely.
Look at the lockdowns.
It's based on science.
on science.
I find it interesting that there are now
all these visionaries
in the world that have are having dreams
and there's a little 4-year-old girl in
the Philippines who had a dream.
And she dreamt that uh they were coming
after them with the vaccines and she
dreamt of Dr. Fauci and uh Bill Gates
coming and that fortunately all
Christians were raptured just before it
happened.
But all those that were behind it was
total disaster.
But be that as it may.
Science is in the mix and descriptive.
Another issue is all of us have to be on
the same page.
That's another important point. In other
words, for the sake of the common good,
everybody must think the same.
Same. Like you said, our watches should
be synchronized.
Our watches must be synchronized. And
the youth must be used to push the issue
just like the Pope used
uh
Greta. Yeah. And they they spoke about
Greta. Yes.
And from what I've also read, they
actually gave one of those model clocks
that they made to Greta. Uh-huh. And
that Greta movement for people that have
don't are not up to date with it, like
they mentioned, 2 and 1/2 thousand
places around the world that were
getting together again for this
movement. It's not That movement didn't
disappear, you all of the sudden.
So, there is a deadline.
They have a year.
Sometime in 2027,
this action must be in place. In other
words, what do they want in place?
Because they said the politicians must
be influenced and must be forced
to bring about legislation to change the
issue.
Isn't that interesting?
Very interesting.
Does the Pope
support
the view?
Absolutely.
He wrote an encyclical on it.
Absolutely. And I'm very interested to
hear what he's going to say in the next
few days
when his new encyclical comes out, but
we'll talk about that. So, bottom line
from this little video, they have a
timeline.
I'm not saying they're saying this is
the end of the world, but they have a
timeline when they want legislation in
place based on scientific data that
brings the whole of humanity onto the
same page for the common good. And I'm
wondering what legislation will that be
and
will it have a religious sting to it?
That's the bottom line.
Good. Let's move on.
Now,
here is the Japan Times from the 23rd of
September and it is talking about
avoiding a climate lockdown.
So, we've had a practice run with a
COVID lockdown.
Now, they're saying if we don't shape
up,
then there will be a climate lockdown.
So, was that a practice run?
Well, you remember how many articles
came out about how clean the air is in
China, the in Venice, the the canals
were clean. And so, they've pushed this
and even the the Pope, he said this was
nature having a fit. So,
and I I was wondering how with after the
very first few days of lockdown, how the
rivers got so clean so quickly. It's
amazing, right? No sewage went in.
Everything stopped. Everything stopped.
I get so many
notifications of people that think
that the scientific fraternity is the
one that one should listen to in terms
of all the aspects.
Now, I'm wondering, do these people also
think the scientific fraternity
should be listened to when it comes to
the philosophy of evolution?
Yeah. Is there I'm not I'm not knocking
science. I'm a scientist myself.
There's nothing wrong with science,
but the philoso- philosophy that runs
science, that is where the problem lies.
And if you can use science to push a
philosophical agenda,
then we are on very dangerous ground.
Then it's not the religious world asking
for this.
It's the scientific world. This god
called science is saying, "You better
shape up or ship out, right?" Yes. So, I
find this one very fascinating. As
COVID-19 spread earlier this year,
governments introduced lockdowns
in order to prevent a public health
emergency from spinning out of control.
In the near future, the world may need
to resort to lockdowns again.
This time to tackle the climate
emergency.
Now, if this was a practice run, this
thing will probably be in this one,
right?
Shifting Arctic ice, raging wildfires in
the western United States and elsewhere,
methane leaks in the North Sea are all
warning signs that we are approaching a
tipping point on climate change when
protecting the future of civilization
will require dramatic intervention. We
have a clock.
Yes, now they've got clock. It's set for
2027.
I can't help find that finding that
interesting.
Under a so-called climate lockdown,
governments would limit private vehicle
use,
ban consumption of red meat.
That is more than fascinating.
And impose extreme energy saving
measures while fossil fuel companies
would have to stop drilling.
To avoid such a scenario, the world must
overhaul its economic structures and do
capitalism differently.
Then the window for launching a climate
revolution and achieving an inclusive
recovery from COVID-19 in the process is
rapidly closing.
So, they have an agenda and they are
pushing it. Every fiber of humanity's
being
is geared to move in this direction.
And
the timeline.
The timeline. Now, we just need to bring
religion into the mix.
And then we have
prophecy
fulfilling before our very eyes.
In a way that we might not have expected
it, but nevertheless, coming that way.
Here's the Religious News Service, also
from September 2020. Pope Francis
launches his post-COVID agenda
with announcement of a new encyclical.
So, there's a lot of speculation. Mhm.
A lot of
expectation
as to what is he going to say. Exactly.
With the announcements of a new document
coming this fall,
Pope Francis is launching his agenda for
world after the pandemic, one in which
nations and individuals will rethink
economic models
and create a more just system. Isn't
that what we just read in the previous
article?
Mhm.
But, you know what? There's something
that's fascinating to me. This picture
A picture speaks a thousand words,
right?
Yeah.
Everybody is wearing masks
on that side of the fence.
It doesn't seem as if anybody's wearing
a mask on this side of the fence.
So, I'm wondering whether this barrier
over here
is COVID-proof.
It must be.
It can't cross that barrier, right?
It's just interesting that one who is so
interested in having all humanity obey
all the rules and follow
the guidelines is so blatantly ignoring
them over here.
Nevertheless, let's continue.
Vatican spokesman Matteo Bruni confirmed
rumors on Saturday,
September 5th, of the release of a new
encyclical by Pope Francis on human
fraternity.
The title, Brothers All.
This is very ecumenical.
Mhm.
Is inspired by the words of St. Francis
of Assisi.
The Pope will sign his third encyclical
at the tomb of St. Francis in Assisi on
October 3rd, the day before the feast
day of the famous friar.
They always have to have special days,
special circumstances.
Yeah. Jubilees and feasts.
That will That will make it prominent,
right?
Mhm.
And he proposed a plan to resurrect
after coronavirus lockdown. The plan is
anchored on the global
interconnectedness
that became so apparent during the
pandemic. In another speech on September
1,
Pope Francis addressed faithful on the
World Day of Prayer for the Care of
Creation.
And what was the memorial of to creation
again?
The Sabbath. The Sabbath.
Stating that the pandemic has brought us
to a crossroads. So, the bottom line is
we have the secular world saying there's
a window of time, we have to act. And
here we have the religious world already
planning the post
pandemic agenda. Yeah.
Peru's prime minister supervises
compliance with nationwide Sunday
curfew.
So, we said Sunday will be in the mix,
right?
So, the Peruvian prime minister, Walter
Martos, flies over various parts of the
capital city Lima
to verify the compliance with a
mandatory social immobilization
measure decreed by the government to
prevent the spread of COVID-19.
Now, did he fly on a Monday?
No.
He flew on a Sunday. To make sure that
they comply
to the immobilization measure.
Yes. So,
this there was a Sunday curfew, and
flying around This is just interesting
to me that
this might be
a precursor of what we can expect. It It
seems to me almost like they're writing
a Talmud of how far you may walk on a
Sabbath day, right?
Immobilization tells me you're not
allowed to walk at all. At all.
Yeah.
This is the first Sunday under the
curfew after the quarantine was lifted
in most regions across the country last
July.
It must be noted that during the
mandatory social immobilization,
strictly necessary personnel
who participate in the provision of food
supply, health, financial, and
restaurant services for home delivery
will be exempted from the restrictions
to transit freely.
The measures will be in force all day
long until 4:00 a.m. on Monday.
Last Wednesday, President Martín
Vizcarra announced the return of the
mandatory social immobilization curfew
on Sundays
due to a rebound in a COVID-19 infection
in Peru.
What do you say about that, Mark?
I don't know. It's just interesting that
it How does it work? They just single
out Sundays every time.
Every time?
Every time. So, it's in the mix.
Yeah, like you said in the previous or
episode,
it's interesting that
the virus is very active on a Sunday.
Yes, it has to be curtailed.
Now,
this is a prophetic scenario.
Yeah. This is an unfolding of prophecy.
And uh if you don't see it,
well, then you're not reading the news.
You're not reading the news.
Now, this one is
is actually quite fascinating. It's
actually more than fascinating. It is
horrendous, shocking.
I don't want to say frightening. I don't
want to use that word. No.
Because frightening means that you do
not understand the prophetic scenario.
Mhm. It's going to happen.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Exactly.
If it's going to happen,
perfect faith
drives out
fear.
So, I'm not going to use the word
frightening.
No.
But, shocking Mhm. is fair enough.
So, this was from the 22nd of September.
Daniel Andrews demands extraordinary new
law to let Victorians arrest each other.
As top judges warn of abuse, and
critics say he's creating his own
version of the East German secret
police.
Allow any person
the government considered appropriate to
be authorized to exercise emergency
power, including make arrests.
There would be no requirement for them
to be police officers or even public
servants.
So, this is a new law
that is in being introduced.
Yes, yeah. He's pushing for this this
Daniel Andrews. And uh the Bible says
that this is going to happen.
Where the
Bible tells us that families will be
arrayed against each other, family
members. That there will be betrayals.
Mhm. And those that even kill you will
think that they are doing God a service.
And we understand from the spirit of
prophecy
that at the end, the populace will be
given permission
Mhm.
to even kill.
Now, are there any precedents of this
nature? And we've mentioned them before
on WhatsApp. The answer is yes.
Mhm.
When Martin Luther stood under the ban
of the church and the state,
he was
declared
to be free range, free game.
And on a certain time and a certain
date, anybody
was allowed
to arrest him Mhm. or get rid of him.
Yes.
And we are heading in the same
direction.
Yeah.
Now, I remember a few years ago I was
lecturing somewhere, I can't even
remember where.
And I was talking about these issues,
and how it will be that we'll get to
this stage
where people will be given permission to
arrest or even go further to execute
someone.
And people said, "That will never
happen. Never."
Now, look at this.
Not only that, if you look at the news
headlines today,
I mean, how many cases have we now read
about where a person walks into, let's
say, a store and he doesn't have a mask,
and the security guard, who's not a
policeman, shoots him.
Mhm.
Because he doesn't have a mask on.
There is also be um some videos
doing the rounds of how people are
getting treated Exactly. if they don't
wear a mask or And not only by the
authorities,
by by members of the public.
Yes, public. And do you remember in um
that
Trump
they gave incentives to people that were
um
giving information on if they saw people
not adhering to the COVID rules. Uh-huh.
Now, that's exactly how it was. And this
person is perfectly right.
This is exactly what it was like.
They're saying East Germany. It was like
that
in many, many countries
where the populace becomes the spy of
the neighbor.
It was like that in Nazi Germany,
and it's like that at the moment because
there have been incentives that have
been created where if you tell about
your neighbor who's not complying
according to your view to these
regulations, then you should hand him
over.
So, we are heading to a point where
humanity is going to take the law into
its own hands by permission of the
state.
Yeah.
Fascinating. That's a prophetic event.
Definitely.
Here's the Croatia week, September 21,
and it says Croatia heading towards
work-free Sunday.
Croatia is heading towards a work-free
Sunday in the direction of half of EU EU
countries where Sunday working in shops
is restricted.
Regulating and restricting Sunday
working is also in line with the
directed of work-life balance adopted by
the European Parliament last year,
which has to be incorporated into the
national legislation of EU countries by
2022.
So,
not only are they using it for climate
change,
Mhm.
they've actually done the work already.
It's in the legislation.
Yes.
And it is creeping up just as the spirit
of prophecy said it would.
Like a stealth
plane. Exactly. And people are
not seeing it.
No.
And they're saying
there's no image of the beast.
There's no mark of the beast. There's no
talk of the mark of the beast. It's
everywhere.
It's just so well disguised.
Yes.
We've seen the political side.
We've seen the religious side. Mhm.
We've seen the Sunday.
We've seen how it is being introduced
into legislation even by the EU.
Mhm.
Now,
the Pope talks about this brotherhood of
humanity. Now, humanity is still pretty
divided. Mhm.
So, if humanity is going to go forward
in brotherhood, then all the parties
must come together. Yes. Then the
Chinese must be on board. The Americans
must be on board. There must be
brotherhood and peace between all of
them. Mhm.
And so, the United Nations will also be
involved, right?
I think they will play a very prominent
prominent role. Okay. So, let's have a
look what what the speech is all like at
the United Nations and see how we can
fit this all together.
We will distribute a vaccine. We will
defeat the virus. We will end the
pandemic and we will enter a new era of
unprecedented prosperity, cooperation,
and peace. As we pursue this bright
future, we must hold accountable the
nation which unleashed this plague onto
the world, China.
The Chinese government and the World
Health Organization, which is virtually
controlled by China, falsely declared
that there was no evidence of
human-to-human transmission.
Later, they falsely said people without
symptoms would not spread the disease.
The United Nations must hold China
accountable for their actions. By
contrast, after I withdrew from the
one-sided Paris Climate Accord, last
year America reduced its carbon
emissions by more than any country in
the agreement. Those who attack
America's exceptional environmental
record while ignoring China's rampant
pollution are not interested in the
environment. They only want to punish
America and I will not stand for it. If
the United Nations is to be an effective
organization, it must focus on the real
problems of the world. We intend to
deliver more peace agreements shortly
and I have never been more optimistic
for the future of the region. There is
no blood in the sand. Those days are
hopefully over. America is fulfilling
our destiny as peacemaker, but it is
peace through strength. We are stronger
now than ever before. Our weapons are at
an advanced level like we've never had
before, like frankly, we've never even
thought of having before. And I only
pray to God that we never have to use
them. And I am proudly putting America
first just as you should be putting your
countries first. That's okay. That's
what you should be doing. I am supremely
confident that next year, when we gather
in person, we will be in the midst of
one of the greatest years in our history
and frankly, hopefully in the history of
the world.
We are therefore facing the choice
between two different paths.
One leads to enhancing multilateralism,
the expression of renewed global shared
responsibility
and solidarity based on justice
and achieving peace and unity for the
human family,
which is God's project for the world.
The other option
gives priority to self-sufficiency,
to nationalism, protectionism,
individualism,
and isolation.
This option
excludes the poorest, the most
vulnerable.
A new ethics entails being mindful of
the need
for all to commit to work together
to close tax havens, to avoid tax
evasion and money laundering
that deprive society.
And also to highlight the importance of
upholding justice and the common good
over the interests of companies and the
most powerful multinationals.
We must be honest and admit
that while some progress has been
achieved,
the international community has not
truly been able to fulfill
most of its promises from 5 years ago.
And this leads me to reiterate that we
must avoid every temptation to fall into
a declarationist nominalism,
which would only assuage our
consciences.
The United Nations was established to
bring countries together
as a bridge between people.
Let us use the UN to transform our
current challenge into an opportunity
so that together,
once and for all, we can build the
future we want.
We are not a bargaining chip in US
elections and domestic policy.
Any US administration after the upcoming
elections will have no choice but to
surrender to the resilience of the
Iranian nation.
And for the world,
today is the time to say no to bullying
and arrogance.
The era of dominance and hegemony is
long over.
Our nations and children deserve a
better and safer world based on the rule
of law.
So, that was the recent United Nations
discussion. Yes, the three people that
were speaking,
the president of the United States, the
Pope of the Holy See, and then the
Iranian president just
for the for the sake of contrast.
Yeah.
Now,
it's interesting the way Donald Trump
spoke was very much in line with
biblical prophecy.
That the second beast of Revelation
chapter 13 will force the world. Mhm.
He said, "No blood in the sand. So, he
doesn't want the war, Mhm.
but let me tell you that we have the
means
Yes, that's why
to force you."
with the military. Yes. Right after
that, too. So, that is very much in line
with the biblical scenario.
On the other side, you had the papacy
saying, "No, we're looking more for a a
socialist model and not this nationalist
model.
And we need a more inclusive model that
everybody is incorporated in."
And then you have the Iranian
that says,
"Nobody's going to prescribe to us. It's
going to be
uh we that go our way and everybody will
just have to fall in line with that and
accept that."
Well, I've got news for them.
Somehow,
that will be mixed together and they
will form a unit and the whole world
will eventually
prescribe the mark of the beast. Mhm.
Now, the only way I can see it happening
at the moment
is through the climate change
agenda. Yes. Because that affects the
United States with its philosophy, that
affects China with its philosophy, Iran
with its philosophy,
and the Holy See as the glue cementing
them all together.
Even Trump,
who pulled out of the Paris Accord,
mentioned here that although they pulled
out,
and then he goes on on what they did to
save carbon and all of this.
That they're ahead of all the other
countries. Yes, so even they are running
with the carbon agenda. So that's the
United Nations. I believe they're going
to play an important role.
And even the Pope said that they
he wants them to play an important role.
And if you listen to most of the
speeches that were given
I think 99 if not all of them were
mentioning the COVID and then also
climate.
Now
having given this background, we have to
see how the religious component is going
to mold the minds of humanity
to really want to come on to the
prophetic page as it has been predicted.
So we will have to go into some of those
issues.
So Martin, you've cut together a video
here
which talks about the Supreme Court
development at the moment and the way in
which the United States is moving.
Remember that the Bible says there must
be an image of the beast that will form.
Church and state has to come together.
And the Democrats, they under Schumer
are very concerned that
religion will have no say in the matter.
And
the young lady Cortez is very concerned
that her body is her domain and nobody
else's domain. Tell us a little bit
about this video.
this video that's been put together now
just shows the difference or the
different
views. The you've got the
Democrats, the views of them, then
you've got Trump defending his view on
why he chose Amy and then we've got the
Catholic side that
they Dr. Taylor Marshall
also
giving their side on this um
nomination of Trump. So bottom line is
can we keep religion out of politics?
Yeah. Doesn't look like it, right?
It's going to be in there.
Let's just have a look. And and and
again, it's issue of north versus south.
Yes.
North being the religious pushing the
Babylonian model, south being the
secular model, right?
Correct.
Let's have a look.
She said, "My most fervent wish is that
I will not be replaced by a new until a
new president is installed."
We believe that.
So did the American people. Today
a Reuters poll came out and said 62% of
Americans agree with her.
It's extraordinarily important that we
understand the stakes of this vacancy.
Our reproductive rights are on the line.
Our labor rights are on the line. Our
right to health care is on the line.
Labor and union protections are on the
line. Our climate is on the line.
And we only need two more senators
to say that they will abide by RBG's
wish.
Two have already said it. We need two
more. Yes.
And to Mitch McConnell, we need to tell
him
that he is playing with fire.
We need to make sure that this vacancy
is protected, that our election
continues, and that the American people
have their say. Thank you very much. We
have
noticed some comments made in the media
about my
incredibly qualified nominee, Amy.
The New York Times said her religion is
not consistent with American values.
She's Catholic.
It covers a lot of people. That's a very
disgraceful thing to say. Some of the
comedians, I don't think they're
comedians cuz comedians are supposed to
be funny. They're not funny like at all.
They're nasty, they're mean, and they
think they're funny.
And someday
hopefully it's in 5 years, but someday
when I'm not here, they're going to be
off
television cuz their ratings, which
aren't very good anyway, but their
ratings are going to go down like you've
never seen before.
And that includes a lot of others also.
In fact, I'm sort of waiting for the New
York Times and the Washington Post
ABC, CBS, NBC
CNN, MSNBC. I I'm waiting for them to
endorse me.
Because if they don't
they're going to drop with a third like
you know, it was supposed to have
happened long ago and then we won a race
and it was a great it was a great
victory and uh I think we've never had a
more energized base. I don't think so.
Nobody's ever seen anything like it. The
rallies that we're having are
incredible. We call them protests.
Though on the religious situation with
Amy, I thought we settled this 60 years
ago with the election of John F.
Kennedy.
But seriously, they're going after her
Catholicism. I
will stand
with her, fight with her, and we will
make sure that these attacks stop
because they really it's unprecedented.
They're basically fighting a major
religion in our country. This is
incredible.
Fighting any religion, fighting
Catholicism is just incredible that they
can be doing it. I'm going to go ahead
and say it.
President Donald Trump just won the 2020
election. You do not realize how big the
death
of Justice Ginsburg is in this election.
And if President Trump can successfully
place Amy Coney Barrett
into the Supreme Court
do you realize what's happening in the
United States of America? Let me tell
you, a lot of you are praying that
rosary every day. You're on the team.
This is the kind of stuff that we small
finite humans we can't understand
what God has in plan. We have to pray
and give it to God and then he has a
plan of how he's going to make things
right
in this world.
Marriage is a sacrament.
The Protestants were so wrong when the
Protestants said marriage is not a
sacrament. They screwed themselves over
big time.
And they screwed over Europe and they
screwed over Western civilization when
Luther and Calvin and Cranmer and all
these
I can't say.
All these guys said marriage is not a
sacrament.
Marriage belongs to
the secular state and not to the church.
That was bad. That was bad.
Well, that's quite a mix, right?
So you have the king of the south view
you have the king of the north view
and then you have the plain
unadulterated Catholic view.
And they don't seem to agree one with
another, do they? No.
Be that as it may.
We're not going to go into the issue of
whether marriage is a sacrament or
whether it is not a sacrament. Uh
the Roman Catholic Church believes of
course that a sacrament is something
that adds to your salvation, right?
So it is a means to salvation.
And there are various sacrifices, so
certain things that you do determine
your salvation.
And Protestantism was quite right when
it said nothing that you do adds to your
salvation. Salvation is by faith
in the atonement of Jesus Christ.
That doesn't negate good works. It
doesn't negate doing the right thing.
But any ritual that you can perform or
any any
pilgrimage that you undertake cannot add
to your salvation.
So I don't think our Catholic friend
understands that issue fully in terms of
where Protestantism comes from.
But that's not the point here.
The point is that the divide between
Protestantism and Catholicism in terms
of doctrine is as great as it ever was.
And yet they're going to combine. Yes.
Yet they're going to work together.
In the past presidents have warned
against Catholicism. They've warned
against the Jesuits.
Preachers warned against Catholicism.
Not against Catholics. I have nothing
against any Catholic, but against the
doctrine
which is a doctrine of salvation
by what you do and by your works rather
than a doctrine of salvation
where you rely on the atonement of Jesus
Christ, right?
So
this this union of Catholicism and
Protestantism
is predicted in the Bible.
This union of Catholicism and
Protestantism is predicted in the spirit
of prophecy.
And Donald Trump said, "Well, this is a
major religion." Mhm. It's part of the
system.
Isn't it interesting? I don't know if
I'm putting you off course now, but
how many I mean
on the courts, the justice
most of them are Catholic. Most of them
are Catholic. We have a Catholic
virtually a Catholic run Supreme Court.
Yes. And if Amy is confirmed
it will be a
complete takeover as it were. It's also
interesting to me that all these role
players
are all part of
organizations within Catholicism and
we'll have to look at that.
at that now. And it just just
another side one that I want to mention
that you also hear that Trump said
that if these news agencies don't get
start endorsing him
they'll
they're going to have problems.
to have a problem. In other words, he
feels that he is King of the North
approaches on a roll, right? Yes.
Now, I'm very interested in all of these
things happening. Now,
here is an article in The Guardian which
gives us a little bit more information.
Amy Coney Barrett spotlight falls on
secretive Catholic group People of
Praise.
Mhm.
Donald Trump's nomination of Amy Coney
Barrett to the Supreme Court to replace
Ruth Bader Ginsburg has drawn attention
to a secretive Catholic covenant
community
called People of Praise that counts
Barrett as a member and faces claims of
adhering to a highly authoritarian
structure.
It's almost like something
that you would expect in Opus Dei,
right?
Mhm.
Where the authority of the church is
absolute.
And
if you look at the the people that Trump
has nominated
they come from Knights of Columbus.
Yes.
They come from this this covenant
community.
Uh
the Bible is very clear that Jesus says
he did nothing in secret. What are all
these secret societies doing? Mhm. And
why are all these people members of
these secret societies? They think that
they are doing humanity a service Mhm.
by doing this, but uh God never operated
like that.
What you see is what you got. You didn't
have to work behind the scenes. Jesus
said, "I have done
nothing in secret."
They write here, "A lot of what goes on
in People of Praise is not that
different
than what goes on in a lot of right-wing
or conservative Catholic circles."
Said Heidi Schlumpf, executive editor
for National Catholic Reporter which
reports on the church. Whether People of
Praise rises to the level of a cult
"I'm not in a position to make that
judgment. But there is a level of
secrecy that was concerning.
And there was a level of reports by
people who left the organization of
authoritarianism
that is concerning as well.
So, some people are put off by this kind
of activity. But this is exactly in line
with how the Jesuits operate.
Mhm.
They also are absolutely authoritarian.
They have a general and they will obey
him like a corpse.
Yeah. So, this this issue of obeying a
human directive, a human guide, a human
coach, a human leader is not in the
order of God.
Mhm.
We have the Bible and we have the Holy
Spirit as our guide and we are to take
our marching orders
by our conscience mediated
through the Holy Spirit and God.
Yes.
Now, many of them as we said were Jesuit
trained.
And
with this authoritarian highly
authoritarian structure
whose authority swings the scepter?
Well, the church. The church, the
papacy. The papacy, the Holy See.
They swing the scepter.
So, in other words, you have the
position here where the church can swing
the scepter politically even through the
Supreme Court.
Yes. It's actually interesting, yeah.
You have Kavanaugh on there, you have
Amy on there, you have all the other
Catholic uh
judges on the Supreme Court. So, if ever
there is a decision and of course the
great fear is that they will reverse Roe
versus Wade etc. But that's not my
point. I'm not arguing about the people.
I'm not talking about whether these
people are nice people or not nice
people.
That's not the issue.
The issue is does the church through its
authoritarian
structure
have access to the mind of these people
to influence them in a certain
direction, yes or no?
Yes, definitely. And
like you said, now it's in the courts
and it's also in the government.
Because you've got the Secretary of
State. You've got all these thinkers
All of them are in it. the same. So,
this is a very very serious issue. And
the Bible tells us
that the second beast will do the will
of the first beast and implement its
directives.
And the structure is in place. That's
the prophetic picture that we're looking
at.
The Business Insider tells us that
historians and election experts warn
Trump is behaving like Mussolini and
despots that the US usually condemns.
Now, this is very interesting.
President Donald Trump is refusing to
commit to a peaceful transfer of power
threatening to shatter a tradition that
lies at the heart of the democratic
process in the US. This is pure
speculation. He hasn't done anything of
the sort as yet. They just think he's
going to do it, right?
he and it's because he
when they asked him, "Will he go
peacefully or he
uh he said, "We'll have to see." Well,
that's the scenario.
So, the clearest parallel is that
Mussolini was prime minister of a
democratic coalition government from
1922 to 1925.
And during that time he slowly chipped
away at democratic institutions,
insulting the press, using violence
against the left joking that he would be
in office for 20 years, establishing a
militia and a legislative body, the
Grand Council loyal to him.
So, they're drawing parallels. Now, I
would like to draw another parallel.
Mussolini is the one that was
instrumental in the healing of the
wound.
Yes.
The He gave the papacy back its
political power and its political
territory and independent Vatican state.
And that was a prediction in prophecy.
I am wondering whether
with this comparison they might be right
in a certain aspect and we will see that
in the future.
Mhm.
Will Donald Trump be the one who gives
the power
back to the church and acts on behalf of
the church? Then he will be a Mussolini.
But he wasn't the one who started it.
No. Ronald Reagan started it.
Yes.
Remember when we go back in history
the magical moment, Time magazine, and
how Reagan and the Pope conspired
to assist Poland's Solidarity movement
and hastened the demise of communism and
it was called the Holy Alliance.
Well, you remember in a previous episode
where when Trump spoke in Poland
and he mentioned that that when they got
together and spoke and Pope Paul
John Paul the II was there and this
They're pushing this agenda, right? This
agenda.
Now it's interesting that prior to
Ronald Reagan
there were attempts to create diplomatic
connections between the United States
and
the Holy See.
The name of course to me is a misnomer
because there's only one who's holy and
that is God. But be that as it may,
let's not go into that.
They could never do it because the
American public wouldn't allow it.
Yeah. And the churches wouldn't allow
it. There would be a huge outcry. How
can Protestantism reach over the gulf
and grab the hand of Rome, right?
Mhm.
And then Ronald Reagan unilaterally did
it.
The first president that was Catholic
was JFK.
Mhm.
And as Donald Trump said, "I thought I
thought this issue was resolved since we
elected JFK." Yeah.
He totally ignored what Ronald Reagan
did
for a good reason. He didn't want to
remind too many people, I think.
So, it started off there.
And since that time things have been
changing. The Supreme Court has been
changing. It is now Catholic run.
Exactly. It was Protestant. It was
Protestant before.
And the mechanisms have been created
to bring about the fulfillment of
prophecy. Wasn't the Supreme Court
Protestant, then more secular, and then
Catholic?
Absolutely. So, the King of the north
actually took over now.
He's taking over again. You're
absolutely right.
This is also very interesting. US
Attorney General Barr, militant
secularists co-opted separation of
church and state
to attack religious freedom.
Now
we said church and state was going to
come together. Now this is not any
brilliance on our part. This is biblical
prophecy. Yep. And this is a prophetic
movement.
And there were people that said there
there's nothing on the horizon of that
nature.
No. But we see it all over.
Now the last few weeks have been
so instrumental
Yes. that it's absolutely phenomenal.
You cannot deal with all of this in in
one
One. session. No. We're going to have to
divide this into two sessions. Because
what happened at the at the mall Yes.
at the Washington Mall
is the cherry on top.
It brings all of this together.
Together.
And I would love to do it all in one
session, but we won't be able to. Let's
just finish what Barr had to say.
Yes. And then we'll continue with what
happened at the Washington Mall. Mhm.
This is really where prophecy is
fulfilling before our very eyes.
Yes.
Now
US
Attorney General Barr, militant
secularists
co-opted separation of church and state
to attack religious freedom.
So is making the separation of church
and state an enemy of the state. Mhm.
He says, "Yet Americans must know that
separation of church and state does not
mean and never did mean separation of
religion
and civics."
As some of our preachers said previously
in our previous programs, separation of
church and state is from the devil.
Yeah, it's demonic. It's demonic.
The Catholic Church teaches that there
is a distinction between church and
state, but not a total separation. Mhm.
And remember that this man is a member
of the Knights of Columbus. And this
another secret Catholic society that
endeavors to put the papal power back
into the position where it was in the
Middle Ages. Correct. He said this
for the National Catholic Prayer
Breakfast.
Pope Pius called it an error in his 1864
encyclical, "The errors to hold that the
church ought to be separated from the
state and the state from the church."
Dr. Taylor Marshall explained in 2015
video that properly properly understood,
there is a distinction between church
and state
where each governs according to its
particular competence, but not a strict
separation.
That is the Catholic model. That's what
we spoke about in the last WhatsApp.
Yes.
That's the one that you like you That's
the synthesis.
That's where the synthesis where that
where this is heading. You've got the
two extremes, but this is where it's
going. And that is where they were and
that's where they want to be.
But they lost that position. So Hegelian
dialectics, you create complete
secularism. On the one hand, the Iranian
model on the other hand, and then you
get back to the synthesis. This is where
they're going. And that is what the
Bible predicts. They
received the mortal wound. They lost
that capacity. That mortal wound will be
restored. You had Mussolini. Yes,
beginning to heal it. You had Ronald
Reagan, and now you have President
Trump.
And they are healing the wound in its
totality.
So there is a distinction between this.
The Catholic position has always been
what Pope Gelasius described in the late
5th century as the doctrine of the two
swords, and we discussed that in quite
some detail in a previous one. But this
is what is happening right before our
eyes. And these are not people that are
sitting on the sideline.
person say well
a preacher saying this. This is coming
from the
Attorney General of the United States.
Coming from the Attorney General of the
United States.
United States. Now let's listen to what
he has to say.
That crucial link between religion and
liberty so well understood at the
founding
is all too often forgotten today.
In American public discourse, perhaps no
concept is more misunderstood
than the notion of separation of church
and state.
Militant secularists have long seized on
that slogan
as a facile justification
for attempting to drive religion from
the public square and to exclude
religious people from bringing a
religious perspective to bear on
conversations about the common good.
Yet as events like this one remind us
separation of church and state does not
mean
and never did mean
separation of religion and civics.
As late as 1952, Justice William O.
Douglas would write for a majority of
the Supreme Court
that we are a religious people whose
institutions presuppose a supreme being.
Alexis de Tocqueville, the keenest
observer of the early American Republic
praised America's separation of church
and state while extolling
America's union
of the spirit of religion
and the spirit of liberty as the key to
its success.
And Tocqueville identified religion
as perhaps the greatest bullwark against
the descent into tyranny.
What is also noteworthy is he gave he
got to know
prestigious honorary award
at the National
Catholic Prayer Breakfast.
And his speech clearly tells us what the
thinking
in the echelons of power at the moment
is.
And he also
when criticizing the separation of
church and state says that
the coming together is essential for
religious liberty. Mhm.
Now as we discussed before
religious liberty to a Protestant
is something totally different
to religious liberty
for the Roman Catholic Church.
Yeah.
Religious liberty by definition for the
Roman Catholic Church
is liberty to serve the common good.
Mhm.
And he mentioned the common good as
well. Yes.
And the common good is defined by Rome.
Yes.
So in other words, you may exercise your
freedom of religion
worship according to your style as long
as it doesn't contradict the common
good.
And this is where the crux of the matter
lies.
Yes.
You can see this with this whole COVID
situation.
You've got your freedom.
But when it comes to common good, sorry,
you don't have a freedom.
have your freedom. Yes.
So the bottom line is we've seen some
prophetic fulfillments in terms of what
the Bible says is going to happen.
Now we haven't completed this
discussion, so we'll make a part two
where we talk about what happened at the
Washington Mall
and how the religious aspect dovetails
into this.
So that eventually we will have exactly
what the Bible says will happen. May God
grant his people wisdom.
And let us close in a word of prayer.
Our loving heavenly Father
we have known that these things will
happen
because they are so clearly written in
your word.
And we thank you, Lord, that we can see
these things with our own eyes so that
we may raise a trumpet of warning to
humanity
for what is coming upon the world.
When humanity gives up its religious
freedom
to listen to the dictates of an earthly
power
rather than a thus says the Lord
we will have reached the point of no
return.
Almost like a prophetic clock
that is running. We do not know the
exact time when that clock will stop.
But we know that it is very near.
Give us the fortitude and the wisdom to
deal with these things in Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen.
Thank you for watching this video.
To subscribe click here.
When the bell appears
click again to get notifications.
To watch the next video
click here.
Thank you.